this is astral plane ma'am that's like
two really trippy but white big
exposition episodes at the same time I'm
really glad this was the one that can't
follow it up because you know after
waiting a whole week to see these again
it's kind of a nice reminder and like
introduction some of these characters
again psycho there's ice king oh there's
Marceline Oh bouncy house princess we
saw her before right yeah okay so it's
kind of a nice little slow late it's
late back as you know a comet coming at
you even our shoes are kind of similar
like look at that we both have kind of a
black and white I'll just see how like
yeah we're both wearing right I give up
on life pence yes yeah but I haven't
changed these pants since like five
years yeah
so all mines black at the bottom god
damn it okay no yours is like of the
bottom - god damnit okay the episode um
I really like the I don't know I want to
say dreamlike but it even kind of goes
via it's like somewhere between like
being awake and being and kind of
projection or that's the astral plane
lay but yeah I'll be honest I never
actually knew what the astral plane was
I just always heard it said like in
cartoons when they had to say like
science babble and stuff so I I just
thought it was kind of like you know the
you know the outer limits or something
like that just kind of like a world you
don't see that's like so so is that what
is it's like between being awake and
being well it depends on who you talking
to honestly I don't want to get into any
arguments or fights cuz someone will say
it's this no like I said as far as from
what I've read and what I believe it's a
state where your consciousness leads
your body okay and goes to somewhere
else and Finn just kind of leaves his
body and kind of travels around but like
other people believe that it's like an
entirely new like plane of existence
so okay so that that's cowboy goes
through and I like how he doesn't have
control over where he goes his body just
kind of takes him you know and half the
time he's and I've been look in the
right direction he's going backwards and
stuff so I really like that I like he
just keeps flying higher and higher up
till we get to was a space lard is that
what we saw the birth of space lied and
it gets very very existential because
then he meets up with glob which what's
up rod yeah it was like not very and I
forgot the fourth one yeah but the four
versions are names I want just I was
saying cuz I misheard I thought I said
do you ever say Oh My glob he's like no
but gob does I thought you said God for
a second hey you know I want one of them
just to be named God and it's not good
like the all-powerful whatever it's just
one of the other globs or what are the
other roles cuz that'd be hilarious but
yeah so he goes up and he sees there's a
glob and the I think four of them and
you know that this comet is coming and
it's gonna destroy Mars it looks like
and it turns out comes every thousand
years right and some sort of big change
happens every time it comes but this
one's really off its course so the
people on Mars you know in kwig star man
and evacuation man are trying to stop it
and he gets in a talk with Finn and
Finn's like yeah what's the point of you
know all of this if you're just gonna
blow up anyway and not even thinking
about it he just launches towards this
thing and I guess Cobb is dead which
that's another great line just clop is
dead like that's really funny
but watch then they'll make Adventure
Time propaganda saying glob is not dead
and it'll be like this really one-sided
insane ramsley except for some reason
will be a hit and even get a sequel but
yeah so then Finn goes down this comet
is now heading towards Earth those are
draining towards Mars now same towards
Earth but Finn says you know bouncy
house princess I think she these are but
what was in said comet which one the
glod is dead or know what was in the car
meant for a second I'm like what does
that mean yes that's sorry got you again
so which happens in this uh Finn's dad
is in the comment
yeah and he's driving you hit it was
like I guess that's why it's off-course
but Y Z in it at all so yeah I feel like
and I'm not gonna like as we're watching
us on Hulu now like the next two I'm
like man that just seems like a week's
worth of like I'm just seeing the
pictures of the ones coming up I'm like
oh my god this is just like you know
that it seems like the next couple just
give you I'm just the continuing story
so yeah pretty frames to get right back
into it runnin um but no I like but I
liked how is still done their way it's
like sort of this dreamlike state it's
kind of laid back you see
Ice King at a party not hitting along
you see Marceline just playing a song in
the sky you see that weird fox who also
is having that experience too and he's
just doing wasn't a cross worth comes
back so I kind of like that like it's
kind of like this big horrible thing is
gonna happen but it's in this very half
awake half asleep state so no I thought
that's pretty cool
what do you think I like it's kind of
okay I forgot to mention in the last
episode what I thought one thing was
stated was violence begets more violence
evergreen treated Gunther really poorly
hit him pushed him around which at one
point in time
goonter turns and I keep forgetting the
pet's name but ends up hitting the pet
which was kind of out of nowhere because
he was so nice to it yeah you know I am
first I was laughing at that but then we
brought that I'm like that's a good
point actually that really ties into the
message at the end and in this one the
message that I really like him how do I
put it I like loneliness because he goes
from one person to another the Fox who
even in his astral state doesn't even
leave his own home and he's so lonely
and Finn says it as he's pulling away
you know and then he sees bouncy house
print
or bounce house princess who is OCD has
a panic room and has to tell herself
okay I could meet new people I can do
this again
lonely terrified to go out around people
even though she had three things inside
of her but then you see Marceline alone
in the sky just playing to herself and
he brings up you know does loneliness
help you create better things and then
he went even Ice King you know he's
enemy already and then he gets rid of it
all and he's just coming yeah I was
boring anyway so whatever again it's
that whole sense of like all this
loneliness is going on and then he sees
the birth and it's like well maybe
that's more important and it's I think
it's a lot of what kids teens and even
adults go through you know you get to a
certain point where just like
everything's like yeah but what's the
point you know in the end you just kind
of alone you know and all that stuff
where does it go - well you finally have
a kid well maybe that's what it is maybe
that's what keeps you going and in the
end we're all gonna die which is what
you know the comet could represent it's
just yeah in the end yeah we're all
gonna die so what's the point
and God grab glove and dammit crap come
grab crab you know he's like yeah but it
doesn't mean you have to stop cuz she
said he's like juice just expect me to
stand here and let all these people die
then he flies off in tries to you know
he fixes the Comets course you know and
again it's that whole thing of like
where do you begin where do you end in
how should you deal with it and I think
it did it in a very interesting way not
this whole like in the end it doesn't
give you the answer it still kind of
leaves it up to you because when it
comes back down and he's like huh man
wait a minute this is crazy
God's dead pretty much in the end God is
dead and we should go help someone yeah
and it seemed very instinctual to just
like you know someone's trapped here I'm
like well let's just go do that so it's
not just like a choice thing there's
this sense of like it's kind of what he
would naturally want you anyway as cavil
we're almost programmed to do
no that's that's a lot better than what
I use coolyback you can't like them just
like that's a much more well no but
III think you're really hidden I think
all of that is yeah it feels very on the
money and yeah and again like I the way
you say and even him seeing this an
experience that he's experiencing it
alone because I can't see him the only
one I could see him is the Fox well in
that glob but I mean Lourdes yeah that's
well huh
or was he yeah no they must have because
remember you got a ride on him and they
give me yeah that's the only way he
could touch them which is interesting I
was kind of like yeah so they're like
ones he can touch that was kind of
interesting so or it couldn't be taken
that maybe they weren't seeing him he
just happened to be in the right spot
when they you know do the laser thing
and do the birth and everything and then
fly up although he said you know can you
see me it's I think they're hinting that
they can't but they never fully say so
basically if you break it down you have
the Fox who's in his own astral state
can see him cuz they're same plane of
existence and then God God grab you know
that can see him because he's gob gob
gob well that you know and grab so
there's that but yeah maybe with the
large it could just be literally like
you said just happen to be at the right
spot at the right time they don't
actually see him they don't actually you
know hear him and the big boost was just
kind of on accident yeah like if he just
have any right in the center when they
did that blender gave birth cuz I knew
what that they're just showing him birth
I guess I mean just even in the at least
giving him the ride is kind of like oh
well they're bringing him to this thing
but you know like why would they
necessarily show him birth although we
don't know what they are maybe they do
like know everything and uh yeah I can't
like that it's I I think they're hinting
at that they can see him but I like I
can't like no no one the baby the baby
large cuz Ben's like a little baby and
the baby's like
kinda looks down at Finn's oh yeah okay
that they're probably getting more like
celestial beings things out of our grasp
of like human knowledge in a sense maybe
yeah as what can see us
yeah and just his everything the pacing
and kind of how quiet a lot of parts
were and how smoothly and moved and even
just the way he moved I mean I thought
that was very nicely done but do you
know like I said very very dreamlike and
very kind of relaxing but kind of like
almost panicky to like having no control
and then there's a comet coming and
stuff so I really like all that I
thought it was very nicely done so yeah
that's about it for this one and um you
gonna go get that no you're not gonna
get me this time is it a pepper or a
carrot - carrot - carrot - carrot yeah
one that's a pepper No why would my cat
have a pepper why would he have a carrot
because it's right there good point yes